I know you know that black lives matter
Megan Markel continues using her
platform to combat racism and inspire
change this time by making a personal
phone call to a victim of an alleged
hate crime I don't really have an
appetite so it's just I don't want
anyone to ever feel like this that's
Althea Bernstein an eighteen-year-old
biracial woman from Madison Wisconsin
who claims she was set on fire by four
white men while she was driving I made
it home I called my mom I went I drove
myself to the ER Megan spoke with the 18
year old for approximately 40 minutes on
Saturday with Prince Harry joining the
combo for about 10 minutes according to
president and CEO of Boys and Girls
Clubs of Dan cami Michael Johnson who's
also been acting as Bernstein's
spokesperson the challenge Johnson told
Wisconsin local news channel 3000 that
Meghan chatted with Bernstein about
quote the importance of self-care and
allowing herself to heal adding that the
Duchess quote applauded her for the way
that she responded man lifted her
spirits today
Bernstein previously opened up about the
attack during a June 24th appearance on
Good Morning America I am very very
hopeful that these men sort of see all
the responses and that um they know that
they hurt me and that this is something
that's gonna affect me for a while
and they really hope that they choose to
improve themselves according to Johnson
Meghan wants to speak with other girls
in Wisconsin in a Facebook post Johnson
revealed that this is something they'll
be scheduling soon the first thing I
want to say to you is that I'm sorry I
am so sorry that you have to grow up in
a world where this is still present both
Megan and Harry are very committed to
the black lives matter movement this is
going to be an area where we're going to
see the couples doing a lot more work
and taking a lot more interest they be
very busy with the COBIT efforts
particularly how it's impacting on their
charities and theirs
focus is now I'm told shifting on to
this movement that black lives matters
is something that really resonates with
both of them the Duchess recently opened
up about the movement in her virtual
speech to graduating seniors at her alma
mater Immaculate Heart and sources
recently told et that she and Harry have
been listening and learning from
community leaders about black lives
matter amid the recent protests
following George Lloyd's death I
realized the only wrong thing to say is
to say nothing